- And then the battles.
The battles are everything.
And I think mangas do it
great. Animes can perfect them.
Like, a great anime like "Naruto."
I recently reread all of the manga,
and the one thing that I
missed out in the manga
was the Obito, Kakashi fight,
which was one of the coolest
fights ever put to pen on
paper or computer generated.
I don't know how they do it, but again,
you don't get that in the manga.
So I'm like, to me, those
battles mean so much.
(upbeat music)
- You are listening to "The
MANA Podcast" from Netflix.
I'm your host Matt Owens.
I'm a screenwriter,
co-showrunner on the upcoming
live action adaptation of
"One Piece" from Netflix,
and most importantly,
a lifelong anime fan.
The MANA Podcast stands for
Manga Anime Netflix Adaptation.
We're taking a negative and
we're making it our brand
and it's an opportunity for
us to talk about our love
of all things manga and anime.
My goal for this podcast is
to bridge the gap between
Hollywood and the anime community.
I know that there's been
some mistrust between the two
in the past, but what me and
my guest all have in common
is we work in the entertainment
industry and we love anime.
I want to give a platform
to some great people to have
in-depth conversations about
the aspect of anime that keeps
us coming back, the things
that make us laugh, cry,
you know, all of those
wonderful gooey emotions.
Basically, we're gonna talk
about what makes the genre
so important and so special.
So I've invited some of my
closest friends to chat.
We're gonna keep this fun
and casual and we're glad
that you've decided to join us.
This is "The MANA Podcast."
Oh, also there will be spoilers,
so check the podcast
description for the list.
Today, I have a very special
guest with me in the studio,
a man who needs no introductions,
but I'm going to introduce him anyway.
You know him from the
Grand Budapest Hotel,
from the "Spider-Man"
films, and most recently,
"Willow" on Disney Plus and
the upcoming "Scream VI."
The one, the only, Tony Revolori.
Welcome. Thank you so much for joining us.
- Thank you for having me.
- Yeah.
- I'm so happy to be here.
- Before we begin, even
though I gave you the greatest
introduction that you've ever
received from your career,
why don't you introduce
- I agree.
- yourself to our viewers.
- Again, yes, I'll introduce myself again
because I need two introductions
as opposed to none.
- That's how powerful you are.
- Oh. Wow.
I love it. You switched and doubled down.
Okay.
I am Tony Revolori, a
self-professed geek, nerd,
and my credits in that
realm will be tested today.
- That's right.
- But I think I'll pass.
- Well, let's start there then.
Why don't we start with a
couple of your anime credits.
What was the very first anime?
- It was Toonami.
- Hell yeah.
- And I can't tell you what it was,
but I could tell you it's one of four.
It was either "Bleach," "One Piece,"
"Naruto" or "Dragon Ball Z,"
as was any kid born in the 90s
watching early 2000s Toonami
right before Adult Swim,
right after Cartoon Network.
- Well, this is already
a good place to start
to get people angry at you.
Of those four, which is your favorite?
(Tony laughing)
- "One Piece."
- Yeah?
- "One piece" is the one.
- "One Piece" has been the one
that was always great.
But like my brother and
I, we always, like, fought
for whatever reason,
because we were so similar.
It's like you can't choose
the same favorite as me.
So we had to pick, and
I chose "One Piece."
He chose "Naruto" and we both
equally loved "Dragon Ball Z,"
and then we both liked "Bleach" too.
And then, I don't know. The anime stopped.
- But it's back now.
- It's back.
- And "Thousand Year Blood War" has been
- It's good.
- So good.
- Beautifully animated, great fights.
- I think they're like cleaning up
what is slightly weird in the manga too.
- It's been fun to see too
though, because there has,
you know, there's a general consensus
that the "Bleach" anime
kind of petered out,
kind of shit the bed in the ending.
And it's really nice
to see a redemption arc
for such a beloved series.
- Yeah, completely.
And I think beyond even
just the anime petering out,
I think they fumbled the
ball just a slight bit
with the last Great arc, which was Aizen.
And then they tried to pick it back up
with Fullbringers arc,
and that just wasn't a good arc anyway.
So everyone was like, well, we're good.
And plus, there were so many
great new stories coming out,
new anime, mangas.
Mangas, excuse me.
'Cause someone's gonna...
- (laughing) They will come after you.
- That came out like "Fairy
Tail" and "My Hero Academia"
that kind of were the new
kids that said, it's okay,
you can go home and go to bed now.
- And yet "One Piece" has continued.
- And has outlasted so many
of them and it's incredible.
- So your early anime are
actually very on point
for what we wanna talk about today.
Today's episode is really about shonen.
Shonen series. The concept of it.
And so there's a lot of debate
about what classifies as shonen.
So when you think of what
makes a shonen manga or anime,
what are the characteristics for you?
- It's either a group or an
individual who is very young
or has childlike sensibilities.
You're gonna have a lot of
action and you're gonna have
an interesting world that has a new thing.
At least that's what I
think about with shonen.
And for the most part,
for whatever reason,
you'll always love the number two guy
more than the main character.
- Interesting.
- Like, think about it. Right?
"Fairy Tail." Gray.
A lot of people.
- The best character
in the series.
- Sure.
- Wait. Okay, wait.
Who's your favorite
"Fairy Tail" character?
- Either Erza or Gildarts or no, no.
Who's that guy?
The cosmic guy, Erza's boyfriend,
who uses and everything?
- Oh, oh, oh. What's his name?
- Do you know what I'm talking about?
- I know who you're talking about. I know.
Okay. I guess it's time
for a "Fairy Tail" rewatch.
- Yeah, but either way,
I think he is probably
my favorite character.
- Okay.
- But again, shonen characters
like, you think about
it, it's always the cool,
dope, silent type that,
like, every young boy wishes
they could be, but they're actually
way more like the protagonist.
They eat way too much, they're very loud
and they're horrible
kids to their parents.
- You're not wrong, 'cause
there is. There's a lot.
Like, people love Zoro.
Zoro has beaten Luffy
in popularity polls before.
- In popularity, completely.
- People love Sasuke.
- Sasuke.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Sasuke arguably is
more popular than Naruto.
Arguably, the manga should have been about
and could have been about him,
and everyone would've been like, yeah,
that's who we wanna follow.
But of course, you have to follow
the great natured, interesting.
But it is changing.
Like, you look at "Jujutsu Kaisen"
and you're like, wow, interesting.
Okay, it's changing.
- Do you not think that Yuji falls
into that same category
though, as some of the others?
- He does, but he's not naive.
He's not as dumb as normal.
Like, you look at "Black Clover"
and a bunch of these other guys,
it's like, I'm not gonna
come up with a plan.
You guys tell me what to do.
I'm gonna grab whatever weapon or fisties
and I'm gonna go beat
the crap out of someone.
You guys figure out all
the other little things,
while Yuji in "Jujutsu
Kaisen" has his own sense
of intelligence and can
come up with his own plans,
and that's something that I haven't seen
in a Jump Shonen in a long time.
Maybe like "Fire Force," that guy.
- Yeah, no, you're right.
He is more intelligent.
I think another really good
example of an atypical, I guess,
shonen protagonist that we
have right now is Denji.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Denji is a bit of an idiot. Sure.
But not in the same way
that, like, Goku and Luffy
are lovable idiots.
- Yeah.
- Denji, he's a lot more
degenerate than we normally
- Completely.
- see in a main character.
- It's really fun to see that
shift happening where no one
wants the, like, cookie
cutter type that is there.
And even like, you know,
we're bringing it back
constantly to "One Piece" here.
But Luffy, chapter one to
chapter now 1,064, 69, almost 70,
he has shifted so much
and matured so much.
I mean, like, he's still
quite naive and everything
and that's his characteristics
and everything.
But he comes up with plans.
He makes different choices
that the Luffy from,
I don't know, 15 years
ago, would never have made.
20 years ago, never would've made.
- Yeah.
So when you think of a shonen anime,
what is it that comes to mind first?
We're talking about some
characteristics of main characters,
but what are some other elements of it?
You mentioned before, like,
- The worlds.
- Battles.
- Yeah. Battles and worlds, right?
Like, I always find there
are different worlds
and quite the escapism,
which I love dearly
because it lets your imagination
run wild and you always
have interesting, cool, weird powers.
And then the battles, the
battles are everything.
And I think mangas do it
great, animes can perfect them.
Like, a great anime like "Naruto."
I recently re-read all of the manga,
and the one thing that I
missed out in the manga
was the Obito, Kakashi fight,
which was one of the coolest
fights ever put to pen on
paper or computer generated.
Don't know how they do it, but again,
you don't get that in the manga.
So I'm like, to me, those
battles mean so much.
And "Dragon Ball Z," I
think, is the one that really
set it apart, because it
literally is just about
I'm gonna punch you, and
I'm gonna punch you harder
than anyone else can punch you.
- Yeah, and you brought up a
really interesting point also,
that, you know, at least personally,
Shonen Jump is the undisputed.
Like, everything that they-
- Yeah.
- That's what people really think of.
But you mentioned "Fairy Tail."
And there are some very
good series that aren't-
I know "Fairy Tail" is polarizing
within the anime community.
I'm a fan. I don't care what people say.
Yeah, no. Same with "Fire Force."
And you have things like "Shaman King,"
"Seven Deadly Sins."
Like, there are a lot of
other really good series
that are out there that
aren't just in Jump,
but they do still have
these same qualities
that you're talking about.
Like, that is what
makes a shonen a shonen.
In its base definition,
shonen is young boy.
But what's interesting-
Yeah. That's kind of the difference.
Shonen, it's named for
that target audience.
- Oh, it's made. Okay.
- Yeah, it's named after
that target audience
- Wow.
- But you have on the
other end, shojo, which
is for young girls.
But I know, at least for
me when I was growing up
and watching stuff, I loved "Sailor Moon"
and "Cardcaptor Sakura" as much as I did
- Sure.
- "One Piece" and "Naruto" and "Bleach."
So I love seeing everyone loving things
that might not necessarily be-
You have a lot of young girls.
You have a lot of female
fans of the shonen genre.
- Completely.
- And I love that we're
seeing a lot of people
just embracing good stories
and good characters,
even if technically they're
not the target audience
for what the particular series might be.
- But I think the categorization
of this is meant for them,
that is meant for this
is slowly disappearing
as people's likes, wants,
and needs are ever shifting.
And that's what's so much fun
is there needs to be no shame,
no need for you to feel weird
about watching something
that might not be meant
for you, but that's okay.
Watch it anyway 'cause
it is meant for you,
'cause it's meant for everyone.
- And so within that, one of the critiques
that you kind of see of
shonen more specifically
is they don't have good female characters.
Shonen series don't have
good female characters.
- Okay, Interesting.
- Sakura from "Naruto" is a
big, she's kind of unfortunately
like the poster child of that idea.
- By the way, I agree.
- I agree with you also, but
the point that I'm trying
to make is it's not entirely true.
It might be situationally true.
- No, of course.
- You brought Erza up before
who is incredible, one of
the best female characters-
one of the (indistinct)
characters, period, in shonen.
What are some other female characters
that you love from shonen series?
- "Attack on Titan."
You have many of them. You have Sasha.
I mean, that show just does
characters in general, well.
But Sasha Mikasa and Annie.
- Yes.
- It's like both, all three
of them are incredible
characters with their own
characteristics that I love.
Then you have, well, "Chainsaw Man"
is like the new one, right,
where you can really...
- Wait. Have we talked about this yet?
- Oh, you think-
- Are you a Power or a Makima?
- Can I say neither?
- And that ends this episode
of "The MANA podcast."
(Tony laughing)
Thanks for your time, Tony.
(indistinct talking)
- More power than Makima.
But like, Makima's just
a horrible human being
and it makes for an incredible
character, because again,
talking about women
not being written well.
But here's a woman who probably
would've been written as a
man, but written as a woman
and is interesting because she's a woman.
Power is waifu.
Power is like, all right, if I'm picking
someone to marry here, her.
But I can't remember her name.
One eye patch.
- Oh, Himeno.
- Himeno. Himeno is number one for me.
- Yeah, we know. We do
love Himeno around here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. (laughing)
- No, those are good choices.
- Did I survive?
- For not just immediately
saying Power above everyone else,
yeah, you did a fine job.
- Himeno's number one.
Then it's Power.
- I respect it.
- Thank you.
- As long as I didn't say Makima.
- And look.
What I think is interesting
about that though
is I don't like Makima.
- Yeah.
- But it's because Makima
is such a good character.
It's who she is and what she
does that makes me dislike her.
A well-written character
can be a character
who is hated also.
- But I think that's the
issue is that we have
our own personal perceived notions.
And I think even though it's
shonen and they're saying
shonen has a problem, it's
how we view women as well
that I think is a very
interesting thing, right?
Sometimes if you don't like a character,
that might be very, very intentional,
but you don't like her and then you go,
well, I hate that character
and she's written poorly
because we expect, we want
the waifus, we want the women
who do the stereotypical thing,
which is like kind of hide
behind your shone in king
and then, you know, battle, battle battle.
And maybe they're strong enough
too and you're like, cool.
But, like, he's the one who's
going to do the final punch.
So I think it's also the way that we look
at women in shonen, that is an issue.
And Erza was a great combination.
It's like, I'm gonna beat the big bad.
Nod to Gray. You guys sit
in the corner, I got this.
And that's what's great.
And I think a lot of people
were able to kind of accept that
a lot easier and it's something like that.
But while, like you just said,
Makima is an incredibly written character,
yet you hate her and then in
most people's minds, like,
because I hate her, means
she's poorly written.
- Right.
- Because we all want to
like and slash love a woman
in a shonen anime.
- Yeah, no. It's a false equivalency.
'Cause I do.
I believe that if a
character is well written,
you hating them is not-
- Yeah.
- That isn't a bad thing.
It's still a commentary.
You have a strong opinion
- "Fullmetal Alchemist."
Right?
- On someone.
- "Fullmetal Alchemist" had Envy and Lust,
two incredibly written characters.
But it works, because you
knew that they were villains
from the beginning.
- What's interesting about that
is I think that also applies
not just to how women
are written in shonen,
but you know, as to people of color,
that's also a big
conversation in this space
as more fans come in, about
that sort of representation.
And there's actually, there's
a YouTuber who I really like
called Blank Thoughts who has a series on-
- Yes, I know Blank Thoughts.
- Do you? Yeah.
What it means to Be Black
in different series.
And he makes a very interesting point
of we're not asking
for quote unquote black
or Latino representation
in the standpoint,
'cause when you give
what is a stereotypical
person of color character, you
get stereotypical characters.
It's just about having a
well-written character who happens
to be a person of color.
And it refers the same way for a woman.
And I think in one of his videos,
one of the best examples he gives,
which I fully agree with
is Yoruichi in "Bleach."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- She is an incredible
character and there isn't really anything
about her character or the
journey that she goes on
that is so rooted in the fact
that she's a person of color or a woman.
She's just an awesome character
and that's such a great way
to insert representation.
His point is "Bleach" is one of the shonen
that does it the best,
'cause there are a lot
of different people of color.
Even from, just looking at
the main cast, you have Chad,
who's half Mexican and half Japanese,
and that is a part of his character.
The discrimination that he
- Oh, wow. That's right.
suffers in that show has
made him such an outsider.
But he is an integral part of,
- Of this group. Yeah.
- As much of an integral part-
- As he can be within shonen.
- Yes, 'cause once you kind
of really start to bring in
the other shinigami and
stuff, the Karakura Town,
those characters go away.
Other than Orihime, they
go away a little bit.
- Yeah, of course, 'cause
she's got the almighty power
of turning back time.
- Yes.
But I think that applies
to people of color as well.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Just write a good character.
- Who happens to be.
- And people will flock to them.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, like, you look at "One Piece"
and it's like they don't
have ethnicities, really.
I mean, they're drawn
the way they're drawn,
but until Oda put out
and said what ethnicity
they come from, then people
started really kind of claiming
that person as their own and whatever.
But in all honesty, it's everywhere.
And he takes inspiration from everywhere.
Brook is inspired off of "Flash."
At that point, what do you...
That's that character and it's dope.
- So what are in the vein of-
Talking about representation
in shonen series,
what are some of the things
that you think shonen series
can improve on, other than representation?
We've covered that a little bit,
but are there other
things that you're like,
okay, when I look at the genre,
are there things that are stale to you?
Are there things that you
think that it could do
different or better?
- Of course.
I wouldn't call myself
the leading authority,
and the things that I want.
- No, that's me.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly. That's you.
The things that I would be interested in
is more a reflection of
myself and where I am now.
I would love to see more
thoughtful, dramatic storytelling.
I would love to, like,
cry with these characters
a little bit more.
And you have it in so many of
these series, like, you know,
even rereading "Naruto"
when Guy Sensei opens
the Eighth Gate and he's like, you know,
we see his backstory.
Like, it makes you tear up.
And I love that and I want more of that,
but I think I'm also more
partial and more sympathetic
and understanding to those
things now that I'm 26 years old
and I want and I know and
I've experienced some version
of this while I have an
11-year-old little brother
and he's reading "One Piece"
for the very first time.
And I saw no tears out of
his eyes when, you know,
Nami is crying and he
puts the hat on things.
I mean, like, he's clearly emotional,
but it's not fully set in for him.
And I'm like, wow.
So to be honest, I don't want
anything to change in shonen.
I do. But that's my own selfishness.
And I think what they're doing
is great and the evolution
that is already happening
with "Attack on Titan"
and "Jujutsu Kaisen" and,
you know, kind of the more
and "Chainsaw Man" and
how different and darker
the storytelling is going
is evident to the authors
growing up with their readers.
But I also want something for
the new generation to come
and read again and be
laughing and crying too,
and be for their generation,
because again, at 11 years old,
my little brother's not
watching "Chainsaw Man."
He's not.
And so I don't want to alienate
the new generation that is coming.
And of course, they have all
the material that we've had
in our past to kind of read
and watch and whatever.
But yeah.
Again, selfishly, I would
love it to continue skewing
more older and having
more dramatic moments,
but at the same time, I'm
happy with where it's at.
And besides the representation,
which we've already said.
- Oh, you're right.
And what's fun is I think we are seeing,
'cause you're right, a lot
of creators, Kohei Horikoshi,
Tatsuki Fujimoto, a lot
of these guys are like,
they're our age.
They came up with this stuff
and they're in their, you know,
like, early 30s and they've lived,
they've experienced a lot of
the same things that we have.
They have grown up with
a lot of the same content
that we have been consuming
and they're taking that
to another level.
So I think you're right.
It's an interesting thing
to look at, you know,
when you have those
classic, like the big three
and things like that and to see
where we've been moving into,
I think there is an emotionality.
One of the things that I love the most
about "My Hero Academia"
is Deku is an incredibly
emotional character.
- Character. Exactly.
- He's prone to crying
and, like, sometimes they
make fun of him for that.
But he is a character
who isn't afraid to feel
and to show his emotions.
And that's something that
I think is really nice
to be giving to audiences.
- 100%, one of the most emotional arcs
in "One Piece" history in
my opinion, is Water 7.
The moment where Usopp and
Luffy are fighting each other
for The Going Merry.
That to me is peak writing
in what could be emotional
stakes and everything.
And you see so many writers
starting to do that,
and it's incredible.
And also, we've always
had the darker stories
leaning towards that.
Like, "Death Note" was
always like, all right,
you have your intelligent
guy who's a megalomaniac
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, with L
and it's still got this shonen tropes.
Anime at this point has become so big,
much like music where now
you can find any sub genre,
sub genre, sub genre of music
that is exactly what you want.
And anime, I think is
following that same trend
because it's becoming so big
where I wanna shonen anime
that has a little bit more
heart or this or that.
And it's like you can,
there's so much out there now
that you can find the thing that you want.
- Yeah, and they're expanding.
You're right. They're expanding
what that definition is.
And the kinds of things,
because you even look
at Shonen Jump in recent years,
they've had massively successful series
like "We Never Learn," which is a comedy,
harem series in Shonen Jump.
And right now, one of my
favorite manga of 2022,
"Blue Box" is just a
sports romance series.
But I read that at the
same time that I read
the new chapter of "One Piece."
It's cool that that kind of
story can be told alongside
some of these really
- Completely.
- battle heavy power anime.
- And that's the evolution
of where we're at,
of any medium that gets to that
point, which is incredible.
And I mean, the thing that
I'm loving even more now
is that you're having anime
being made not just in Japan,
which is great.
And, like, Netflix has
done such an incredible job
of championing that
kind of push to be like,
why don't we do it?
And I think the first
successful version of it
was "Avatar and the Last Airbender."
- Yep.
- I mean, that's an anime
with American sensibility
'cause it's American writers,
but they made an anime
and everyone here ate it up, still.
And so it's just that evolution,
which I'm so excited about and, you know,
new anime coming up, you know.
I'm excited for the day
that maybe I can invent
or create my own.
- No, it's fun to talk
about what the term anime
just on the whole means,
'cause you're right.
There are some people who say
"Last Airbender" is an anime.
It just is.
You have some people who
say it wasn't made in Japan,
so therefore, it can't be.
- It's not an anime.
- So where that line is,
'cause there's a lot of series like that.
You look at, like, "Castlevania."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's an anime.
It is.
- Completely.
- I don't care what people say.
Same with, like, you look
at "The Dragon Prince."
- Yeah.
- It's an anime.
- Dota. It's like they're
taking these inspirations.
But then, it's not just inspirations
if you're doing the same thing, right.
Like, you're not gonna say
someone playing Latin music,
but he's from Switzerland.
You wouldn't say, well,
that's not Latin music
because they're not Latin.
No.
It's still Latin music, just
played by someone who might not
have grown up exactly where
this thing was popular.
But that's not, that doesn't
discount what was made
and the product itself and what it is.
And I think, again, like
you and I were saying,
anime is growing and evolving
and now it's reaching itself
into so many different territories.
But more than anything, it's
becoming popular in The States.
- I'm really glad that teenagers nowadays
don't have the same issues
I did of being called a nerd
and, like, girls not
wanting to talk to you
because you were wearing
a "Dragon Ball Z" t-shirt
from Hot Topic.
- Exactly.
I mean, I made a movie about it.
I was in a movie about it called "Dope."
And, like, that movie is
so telling to the time
of even five to eight to 10 years ago.
Yet now everyone in school,
my little brother's talking
about anime with all of his classmates
and they're all running around recesses
doing kamehamehas and,
you know, Detroit smashes
and stuff like that.
And I mean, I wish I grew up in that era,
but at the same time, I'm
happy to have paved the way.
And, you know, I'm glad that
I don't have to be called
an Oreo anymore or coconut.
- It's made us resilient.
- Yeah.
- Indeed. Thick skin and gorgeous skin.
By the way, I just have to
mention, you have gorgeous skin.
- Thank you so much.
We'll trade moisturizing regimens later.
- Do you actually have
a moisturizing regimen?
- I don't. I just
naturally look like this.
- Me too.
That's a friendship high five right there.
- Yes. It is.
- Good one. (laughing)
- All right.
We've had some good talks.
We've agreed on a lot of things.
Now I want to try and fight you.
- Oh, fight me.
- What's your hottest shonen take?
- Oh god.
- What is something that you
love that's universally hated?
What's something that you
hate that's universally loved?
- Oh my God. Okay.
Ooh. Okay.
I'm gonna stir a little bit of a pot here.
Should I say it?
- Say it.
(Tony laughing)
- Well, you might agree.
But I think Ichigo and
arguably most of "Bleach"
and the ending of "Bleach" is better
than the ending of "Naruto."
I mean, yeah. (laughing)
- I do not agree.
But...
- Okay.
But you see my point?
- I don't.
What I will give you is I
think the Soul Society arc
in "Bleach" is one of the best
arcs in shonen manga history.
- Yes.
- Ever, all time to this day,
one of the best.
- Fair.
- That said, both "Bleach"
and "Naruto" are guilty
of extreme highs and extreme lows.
- Agreed.
I think the highs of "Naruto" outnumber
the highs of "Bleach."
'Cause while you've got
Soul Society on one side,
I think you've got The Chunin Exam,
and what is my favorite
arc in all of "Naruto"
is the Sasuke retrieval arc.
- Okay. Fair.
But you have Hueco Mundo and
the Arrancars and Vizards.
And okay.
(indistinct talking)
- The Vizards.
They're cool, I guess.
But is that really-
- Yeah.
- Is that something you're gonna use
to platform "Bleach?"
- No, I'm not.
But, like, Hueco Mundo
and Ulquiorra and Grimmjow are phenomenal.
Those fight scenes.
And also, Aizen, I think
is a much better villain
and a clearer villain.
Every time Naruto beats someone,
that it's always you win
and now I'm your friend,
and I will do one last thing for you,
because you're such a beautiful soul.
Thank you very much.
While in "Bleach," it's
like, nah, you beat me.
Thank you. That was a good fight.
You got me. And I think
it's more realistic.
It's more fun and you're right.
But the fact that it's 40
chapters from Obito to Madara
and being the ultimate bads
and bads and then Kaguya.
And then now with "Boruto," I think he's-
I don't want to say making it worse.
But, like, now that they're
aliens who give the things.
And I'm like, oh man, you
ruined such a cool world
by explaining way too much of it.
While "Bleach" is like,
look, we explained it,
but it's also, like, still
contained to this secular thing.
And even, again, I agree
with you in saying "Bleach"
has lower lows than "Naruto" ever did,
but I think the highs
of "Bleach" are better
than the highs of "Naruto,"
and I adore "Naruto."
- While I do disagree with that sentiment,
I will concede to you,
villains are better done.
Aizen is a phenomenal villain.
And you're right, the whole,
this is the main villain of "Naruto."
Nope. It's this person.
No, it's this. And then
Kaguya comes outta nowhere.
- Nowhere, all of a sudden. Last 30 pages.
- I can't fault you for that.
- I mean, 30 chapters.
- Also, I just, the other
thing that I will agree
with you on is Naruto
killed my favorite character
in that series and "Bleach" didn't.
So I will always have-
- Okay, okay, okay. Neji?
- Yes.
- And we've talked about this.
- Yes. The greatest character
in the entire series.
- And by the way, having re-read that,
I was a little disappointed
that there weren't more chapters
or more of a moment.
And I don't know why I
remember reading that
for the very first time
and there's a moment
where he whispers in his ear
and I thought he had said,
like, yo, my cousin loves you.
Be with her.
In the official Viz
translations, it's like,
everyone loves you, let's all be happy.
And I'm like, what? No.
Let Neji be selfish and be
like, yo, I'm gonna do one last
good thing for Hinata.
And I'm like, ugh.
To me, as impactful as
that could have been,
you throw it away instantly,
and then not 10 chapters later,
Shikamaru's about to die and he makes it.
But you're like, no, no, no, no.
If you're gonna give us someone dying
or give us a couple of people die.
Even Shikamaru's dad dying,
he was a small character,
but it leveled out where
he got to say his goodbyes.
He got to, like, say, oh, funny joke.
You know that shed that
I have in the back?
Just destroy that before, Mom...
It's, like, that's great.
Neji didn't have that moment.
It should have been a
good two-chapter moment.
Or give us, like, some
backstory of him training
and being like, yo,
Hinata, you and I made up
and blah, blah blah.
Nothing. He just dies.
But now I have to ask,
who is your favorite "Bleach" character?
- Soifon.
- Ah. Really?
- Yep.
- Hot Take.
She's one of my least favorite.
- What?
- I don't like her at all.
- Why? Because you
don't like strong women?
- Oh, how dare you. How dare you.
Yoruichi is phenomenon and I love her.
She's my waifu forever.
- And you know who her waifu is. Soifon.
- No. Soifon's waifu is Yoruichi.
She's following her
around like a little cat.
- No.
- Yoruichi is not-
- Disrespectful.
- No, no.
Who's your favorite "Bleach" character?
- Oh man, probably Hitsugaya.
- Okay. No, that's a
good, safe, basic answer.
- I know.
I've always been into ice
powers since I was a kid.
So I was like, come on, come on.
And also like, he was a
genius and great hair.
Very young genius who could do a Bankai.
I was like, I want that.
- No, Hitsugaya's a good character.
Okay, so that's interesting.
You see a couple recurring,
sometimes, power themes
or abilities or something.
We've talked about Hitsugaya.
We've talked about Gray.
Let's talk about some more ice characters.
What's your thoughts on
Kuzan from "One Piece?"
- The best ice character in
any shonen anime whatsoever.
Not only is he powerful,
and I think what Oda does beautifully
is just because they have
a power that other people
have used before, he
finds new, interesting,
inventive ways to use them.
All right. This guy uses ice powers.
So now, he's gonna ride
a bike on the ocean.
He's gonna make a ring
around the 10 Rings Island
for when they did the Foxy Pirate stuff.
You know what I'm
- Oh.
Long Ring Long Road?
- talking about.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's like, he's like,
here's an ice thing.
It'll last like a week, feel free.
And I'm like, that's so dope.
But then the more we find out
about him, he's just so dope.
Not only is he smart and intelligent,
but he's also peaceful and resourceful.
And to me, that makes for
such a great character.
And I'm so excited.
Now, spoilers alert that.
I mean, we all kind of knew
that he was, I mean, with Blackbeard.
But now officially, we saw him there.
- Do you think that's true though?
Do you think he's actually
- I do not.
- with Blackbeard?
- No.
- I subscribe to the theory
that he's undercover.
- He's undercover.
- He's a member of SWORD
and he's going undercover
in one of the most dangerous
- SWORD or Revolutionary.
- Yes. Either.
- Either.
- But I refuse to believe
he's actually aligned with Blackbeard.
- I agree. I think he's
just there to make sure.
He's like, if you get too
close, I'm gonna stop you.
But the issue is, at a certain point,
you're helping him amass so much power.
Will you be able to even stop
him by the time it gets there?
I mean, look at all of his
stacked crew, which by the way,
I'll give credit to Law.
I thought Law is, like, the
only powerhouse in his team.
But his crew's, like, coming together.
- I'm so tired of people
shitting on Law all the time.
They're always like, Law's
99.9% of the power on his crew.
No.
- He's 90. He's 90.
- Not anymore.
After those chapters of the Heart Pirates
verses the Blackbeard
Pirates, put some respect
on Shachi and Penguin
and Bepo and Jean Bart,
and all the rest of the group.
- I'm not giving you Bepo, but
I'm giving you everyone else.
Bepo didn't do anything.
He was like, oh my god,
you're hot as a woman.
And that's all he did in those chapters.
- I'm tell you, at some
point Bepo is gonna bust out
his Sulong form and everyone
is going to pay respect.
It's gonna happen.
- Give it to me.
I'm ready for it. Give it to me now.
But until that moment,
I'm shitting on him.
- No, I refuse.
- But also, I've won the take.
"Bleach" is better than "Naruto."
- I don't think you do.
- No, no. I won. I won.
- Okay.
You know what we'll do?
In the comments, I want people to vote.
- That's nice. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Bleach" or "Naruto."
This is the discussion.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
But like, you have to
watch this and then vote.
You have to hear my points and-
- Why? They're not gonna help you.
- That's mean.
You have to hear what
I'm trying to say here.
I thoroughly would much rather
read "Naruto" than "Bleach."
But as an objective storyteller
in a industry of storytelling,
"Bleach," I think, has
a more cohesive story.
And they both fall into
the, you're the chosen one,
you have all the powers,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
They both have their faults.
And you know, again, like I said,
"Bleach" has some lower lows.
But I think their highs
are way cooler, man.
And I think their fight
scenes are way cooler.
- Okay, so you're "Bleach" over "Naruto"
in that particular argument.
What to you is the number one
undisputed best shonen series?
- I've said it and I'll
say it again. "One Piece."
The thing is, the way
I view it is what world
would I would love to live in, right?
The "Naruto" world is cool, but
like, you kind of have to be
the chosen person to kind of get anywhere.
Like, even reading the last chapters,
Kiba was like, I want to be Hokage.
And everyone was, shut up. And it was sad.
And he probably had an amazing
dream to actually do it.
They were like, sit down kid.
No, no, no, no, no. Not for you.
It's for one of them too.
So it's just like, ugh, don't love that.
"Bleach," I feel like is one,
not only do I want to have
like an eternal best friend
in a Zanpakuto because
I would make that person
my best friend or sword or
thing, or I don't know, whatever.
But I think the world
is interesting to, like,
continue your power structures.
And then "One Piece" is just
the most free fun world.
You can be powerful with a
Devil Fruit, without one.
You can have fun with
a crew, you can change,
you can do this and the
world is already massive,
yet we've probably not seen all of it.
Like, we've barely seen
any of the east, west,
south or North Blue.
And on the Grand Line,
we've only seen the islands
that our crew takes.
To me, the world just seems so huge,
that I would want to have fun.
Not only that, but I'd want
to have fun with my friends.
I think that is the point of "One Piece."
So to me, that's what I would wanna do.
But now let me ask you a question.
If you can get any Devil
Fruit, what would you choose?
Or any Zanpakuto, what would you choose?
- Oh, it's the Ope Ope no Mi, easily.
It's Law's powers.
- Okay.
- Because it encompasses
so many things.
Do you not remember how confused you were
when you saw him for the first time?
- Completely.
- And they do not
explain his powers.
- At all. (laughing)
- He's just, like, taking dude's heads off
and all of this stuff.
The ability to just control, essentially,
reality in your own little operator room,
'cause he can teleport with that.
- I know.
- There's so much
functionality to his powers.
Part of it might be skewed,
because he's my favorite
"One Piece" character of all time.
- Interesting.
- Oh yeah. Easily.
- Law is the best
character in "One Piece."
- Fair.
- Who's your favorite?
And then we'll do straw hats.
- Okay.
- It's two separate things.
Outside of the straw
hats, favorite character.
Ace. Ace.
Because I used to be
- That's a good one.
- the younger brother.
I had an older brother
for the longest time,
and we grew up watching it.
I was like, I'm Luffy.
You're Ace. You're gonna die.
And then I had a little
brother who was born,
and now all I can do is,
like, bump him on the head
like I'm Itachi and I'm like,
I'm the older brother now.
I must be dark and brooding
and mess with you as much as I can.
Yes. I'm sorry, Sasuke.
So now I, like, feel
the older brother vibes.
So I'm going Ace, outside
of the straw hats.
All right. What do you
say straw hats wise?
- Nico Robin. Easy.
Without hesitation,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- She's easily the best
character on the crew.
- Sanji.
- I love that answer. I love Sanji.
Look.
This is again,
we're given controversial things.
We've talked a lot about
"Fairy Tail" today.
- But I am a Sanji over Zoro,
and I am not ashamed of it.
- I'm not ashamed of it.
- I'm with you there, but I want everyone
to, like, flame me for this.
- Oh, they're going to.
- And I cannot wait.
I will take your anger and I will break
the chains of hatred, like
I'm Naruto. (laughing)
Again, you see how dumb that is.
But anyway, yeah, Sanji.
I love the crew and, like, Luffy is dope.
But I love how smart Sanji.
Zoro's like, got you.
I'm gonna be the cool brooding guy
who's gonna, like, slash slash.
Luffy's like, haha, I'm fun. Punch Punch.
Usopp is like, I'm gonna cry in a corner.
I'm gonna be brave for two
seconds. Saves the day.
I also love him because, like, God Usopp
and everything is incredible.
But Sanji to me, he's always, like,
been the true vice captain.
Like, even as far back as
Arabasta and Little Garden,
when he's on the phone and he's
pretending to be Mr. Prince.
Like, he's the smart guy
who's going to get you out of a situation,
which is why Luffy allowed
him to go off with the ship
by himself at a certain point,
because he knew, all right,
Sanji's gonna take care of it.
If it was Zoro, that could never happen.
Zoro is like, I'm gonna just kill everyone
who tries to touch us.
And Zoro is great, don't get me wrong.
And he commands respect of
the crew, which is great,
but Sanji is the guy you actually need
to be your vice captain.
- And so the people don't think we're just
entirely shitting on Zoro,
to go back to a moment
that you were talking about before.
And again, just for clarity,
Sanji is better than Zoro.
When we were talking about
the Luffy versus Usopp fight in Water 7.
- Yeah.
- Zoro's moment in that
area is one of my favorite
things that he's ever, just
him standing up and being like,
you can't waver here,
because you will lose
the respect of everyone else.
- Every single one here.
Yeah.
- You are the captain, act
like it, is such a wonderful
moment for him as a first mate.
- Yeah, he made Luffy grow up.
And he's the only one besides Nico Robin
or Nami that could do it.
Maybe Jinbe now as well.
But Sanji was the OG,
Luffy, what are you doing?
I know.
But he's been doing it
since the beginning.
Even in Loguetown when the
guy was trying to, like,
Buggy's crew mate, the second,
or mate, first mate, the lion dude.
Richie.
- Oh, Mohji.
- Mohji. And Richie is the lion.
- Yeah.
- Like, trying to burn the
ship and he beat him up.
And even in Water 7,
he's the one on the train
keeping track of Robin.
And that moment where he's
like, I wasn't gonna listen
to you either way, I'm
like, ah, you're so cool.
Anyway, I wanna know more about him.
Like, he's really holding
both those characters
close to the chest.
He's revealed a lot about Sanji
and almost nothing about Zoro,
and I cannot wait for that moment.
But also, there's still
so much more about Sanji
that we need to know,
like the augmentation.
Is he Lunarian?
Is it just like...
Anyway, I have to bring it back
because I wanna know
what's your Zanpakuto?
- Hmm.
I mean, it'd be Soifon's.
I love the design of it.
I love the glaive with the, you know.
- I love her Shikai.
- And just, I hit you
in the same place twice
and you're dead.
- I love her Shikai.
Her Shikai, to me, is
probably one of my favorites.
Her Bonkai, they faltered.
They faltered.
- What do you mean, faltered?
- I don't like it.
It's so big and different
from her character.
And I was like, I wanted like
some cool fast movements.
And you're like, no, no, no.
I'm gonna, like, just blow everything.
- That's what's cool about it though,
is you would expect it, because she is.
She's a nimble character.
She's a close quarter of
combat kind of a fighter.
And then it's like, nope.
Big gun. Pop.
- Yeah. Fair, fair, fair, fair, fair.
- I love it. She's the perfect character.
Great haircut. Great design.
(person laughing)
She's very angry.
- Is that your, like,
ultimate waifu?
- She's one of 'em.
- One of them?
- She's one of them.
- Wow.
- You wanna know? Okay.
I have a throwback, like, OG waifu.
It's Sango from InuYasha.
- Interesting.
Oh my god.
- Oh man. Do I like girls who are mean?
- Yeah.
I was about to say, I think you do.
- Wow, I learned something
about myself today.
- I mean, which is also
why you're a Power man,
'cause Power's kind of...
- Yep.
(Tony laughing)
All right.
We learned something about Matt today.
- We learned something about Matt today.
Do you have more?
What are you watching or reading right now
that you're really into?
- So much. So much.
What am I watching? Everything.
"Chainsaw Man," "Bleach."
I watched recently, "I
Reincarnated Into a Slime."
Love it. It's incredible.
- Yeah. That one comes up
on a lot of people's lists.
- Yeah. Really, really enjoyed that.
Someone told me about this one
show, "Eminence in Shadow,"
which I've been really enjoying.
And then "Tower of God."
- Oh, did you just get
into "Tower of God?"
- Yeah.
- Nice.
- I started reading it and loving it.
And then I watched the
Crunchy Roll animation,
and I love that.
And as for reading, what
else am I reading that's new?
Jump has a good series "Ginka
& Gluna," which I'm enjoying.
What do you recommend?
What should I be reading?
What should I be watching?
- We're both watching "Chainsaw Man."
- Yeah, we are.
- Watched some of it together.
It's a wonderful series.
- Yes.
- Things that I'm reading right now,
A recommendation that I would have is,
I'm a little late to the
game, but I started reading it
earlier this year, "Witch Watch."
- "Witch Watch."
- In Shonen Jump.
- Yeah.
- Very fun series. Very good.
- What is "Witch Watch" about?
- "Witch Watch" is a
series about a young witch,
and witches have, like, watchers.
- Yes. So I've read this.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
I thought it ended.
- No, it's not done.
- Did they take, like, a
hiatus at some point? Maybe.
- It could have been a, yeah.
- I think they took a hiatus and then-
- I'm behind to it, so.
- Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
You're right. "Witch Watch" is good.
Wow. I gotta continue that then.
- Well, Tony, this has been awesome.
Thank you so much for joining us today
Any final words you'd like
to give to our audience?
- If you are listening to this,
you probably already watch anime.
My little last piece of advice
is when you're trying to get
a friend into it, be casual about it.
You're like, oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, you might like it,
but you know, also it's my thing.
And then they'll go, well, no, no.
I want it to be my thing
too, then they'll join in
and then we'll have more
(indistinct) in this group.
So we can all Naruto run
into Area 51 together.
- Well, that's gonna
do it for this episode
of "The MANA Podcast."
Big thanks.
Big thanks to the very
talented Tony Revolori.
You can find him on
Instagram at @TonyRevolori.
- That is my name. I will
change it eventually.
- And then I'm gonna take it.
- Yeah. To Tony D'revolori.
- Oh, that's actually-
I'm gonna do that as soon as we are done
so that you can't have it.
- Oh, I'm doing it right now.
- Thanks a lot, Tony, and
thank you all for listening.
If you enjoyed this episode,
don't forget to subscribe
to our podcast on your favorite app.
Please leave a rating and
review for "The MANA Podcast."
I'm Matt Owens. Thanks for listening.